what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and we just watched miss
marvel episode two and we're gonna break
it down including that ending who
exactly is this woman that kamala has
been having visions of and what is she
doing in comron's car and are kamala and
komron actually related could they
actually be cousins and would that mean
that kamala actually was telling the
truth when she lied to her brother slash
maybe didn't lie to her brother we're
gonna break it all down in this video
including is komron actually red dagger
we going to see him become red dagger in
the next few episodes we're going to
break it all down in this video and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos okay so the first
thing that we have to talk about for
miss marvel episode two is who this
woman is that kamran just casually has
in the back of the porsche when he picks
up kamala khan to save her now we do
know a lot about this character but at
the same time some things still remain a
mystery however as usual gathering all
of the information that we know and all
of the evidence that we've seen so far
combined with knowledge from marvel
comics it looks like we've narrowed it
down to who exactly this might be now
the actress who plays this character is
nimra bucha and the character's name is
najma and i apologize if i mispronounce
some of these names now najma isn't
really a character for marvel comics not
exactly at least but najma means star
and there is a marvel character named
star that has deep connections to
captain marvel in the comics star
actually steals captain marvel's powers
and this could be what she's trying to
do with kamala khan now and big thank
you to paul over at heavy spoilers for
having this conversation with me when i
was trying to brainstorm what was
happening here now i do think that it
would be interesting if najma was indeed
the villain anti-hero star because even
though they'd have to retcon the
character they could seriously make this
work and connect a lot of different
things specifically i actually think
that they could connect this back to
kamala khan's great grandmother starr's
name in the comics her real name was
ripley ryan and she was a reporter who
interviewed captain marvel carol danvers
for tony stark but then they were
attacked by nuclear man a nuclear man
defeated captain marvel and the avengers
but took ripley hostage carol danvers
would go on to save ripley and
eventually ripley would volunteer for a
cree experiment turning humans into cree
hybrids and ripley was the only one that
survived but she had no powers so
instead she decided to take them from
captain marvel and she created a virus
that would then go inside of carol go on
to her heart and this would siphon
carol's powers and give them to ripley
now eventually carol danvers kind of
ripped out her own heart in order to
defeat ripley then she had to rip it out
of ripley's chest as well that defeated
her and ripley was taken to the raft now
here's how i think they could actually
retcon this story to fit in the mcu now
one obviously there's going to be some
pretty big connections to captain marvel
in miss marvel i mean there already have
been but we know that miss marvel is
going to lead up to the marvels which is
really captain marvel 2. now i'm quite
sure najma wants the bengal from kamala
khan but i actually question if she had
some type of run-in with kamala's great
grandmother throughout episode 2 we
found out that she brought shame to
kamala's family but what if everything
isn't exactly what it seems what if it
actually could be najma's doing because
we know that she is actually the main
villain of miss marvel she has been in
some trailers and or tv spots and we can
see that her and kamala are fighting and
it's pretty much known right now that
she's the villain her and it looks like
three other people actually so what if
these people go way back to pakistan and
they ran into kamala khan's grandmother
and tried to steal the bengal back then
and some bad stuff happened but instead
of them getting blamed for it kamala's
great grandmother got blamed for it and
perhaps by the end of this series we
will go on to find out that kamala's
great grandmother wasn't actually
somebody that disgraced her family but
was actually a hero after all we did
hear the story of kamala's grandmother
and how she made her way back to the
train by following a trail of stars and
this was probably her great grandmother
her grandmother's mother guiding her
back to the train while she had the
bengal which was causing the trail of
stars but then had to go deal with some
dangerous situation then at some point
in time in the history of everything she
managed to get the bengal back to her
daughter which was kamala's grandmother
i wouldn't be surprised if this is
somewhat the story that plays out during
the miss marvel series and i'm kind of
expecting kamala's great grandmother to
get some sort of a redemption by the end
of this and i'm betting najma is behind
this so-called disgrace and shame put on
kamala's great grandmother and i think
this is all actually going to be
revealed relatively soon because i think
that perhaps najma and her son kamran
are going to be taking kamala to
pakistan and here's why i think this
we've actually seen trailers and tv
spots that show kamala in what looks to
be pakistan and in some of the tv spots
they have actually revealed the
character red dagger
kareem if you take a look at this
picture right here that is from a
trailer or a clip that marvel studios
put out we can clearly see that this is
the red dagger now it is possible that
they are still in jersey city however in
the comics red dagger protects pakistan
even though at one time in the comics he
does participate in an exchange student
program and he does go live with the
cons in jersey city but since miss
marvel is a pakistani hero and it's a
show about her i kind of assume that
we're going to pakistan at one point in
time in the series and again this is
where i think things are going to kind
of start to get revealed you see in the
comics kareem's mother and kamala khan's
maternal aunt went to secondary school
together but at one point in time kareem
lived with kamala's grandmother in
karachi and at this episode at the
dinner table komal's father said that
his family had been in karachi for
generations and kamala's mother and her
family moved to karachi after the
partition so i'm assuming that kamala is
going to karachi and that's where she's
going to meet red dagger kareem and i'm
assuming that he's going to give us some
truth of what actually happened with
kamala's great grandmother now as i
mentioned in my episode 1 breakdown i do
believe that the bengal that kamala
wears is cree technology and like i
mentioned in the story about star star
volunteered for some cree humanoid
experiments turning people into part
cree part human beings i think this is
something that we might actually see in
this series i think this might be what
najma is trying to accomplish but she
needs the bangle now here's the thing
najma and komron might actually be
somewhat related to kamala that would
make things a little weird considering
that kamala would have had a crush on
her cousin but i'm assuming they're so
separated or are only related by
marriage but najma seemed to know how to
communicate with kamala through the
bengal through some type of cosmic
energy that the bracelet emitted kamala
had visions of najma reaching out to her
so there is somewhat of a connection
there it may not be that they're related
but it might also be that that's the
case also there is a trailer for miss
marvel where najma says that you've
inherited greatness you've inherited
greatness
and this is extremely important because
this means that najma knows kamala
khan's family history most likely due to
the fact that she's been trying to hunt
this bengal down and was probably trying
to get it from kamala's great
grandmother then her grandmother
possibly her mother could have been
involved in some way shape or form but
now she's trying to get it from kamala
also hate to say it but komron is
probably bad he might not be so bad
since he's a young guy but i'm still
hoping that kamala gets together with
bruno anyway so i'm not too upset about
it now the beginning of this episode
starts off with kamala going back to
school her confidence is through the
roof since she has discovered that she
has powers and saves zoe she corrected
the teacher of what her actual name was
she's not getting hit in the face with
basketballs she's interacting with her
fellow peers in a cool way and she's
even shoving people away from her locker
but not doing it in a mean way and as
she leaves she even says that she
encourages the couple and is rooting for
them now of course at school zoe is
talking about how popular she's become
because she was saved by a superhero and
she's acting like she actually knows the
superhero and even gives her the name
night light but kamala is watching zoe
talk about how she saved her and she's
actually kind of happy about it then
nakia comes and she says that zoe is
bragging about being saved by a low
budget captain marvel which would
typically be an insult to any other
superhero however kamala idolizes
captain marvel so she's actually really
happy to be called that and even says
thank you now after school bruno wants
to see kamala's powers and she shows
them to him but she doesn't necessarily
have them under control yet so we start
a training montage in the background we
can see a mural that is done by b mike
and it actually has an instagram handle
that says b mic 2 c this is an actual
artist brandon b mike odums and his
actual instagram handle bmic2c and he
also runs some really good non-profits
you should check them out so kamala
starts to realize that she can create
this hard light and she can actually
learn to step on them she just has to
learn how to make them stronger but i
think the most important thing about
this training montage is that bruno says
that kamala's power is coming from
within her not actually from the bengal
the bengal just simply awakened it this
is kind of a different play on the
terrigen mist activating her inhuman
genes inside of her essentially the
bangle is the terrigen mist but it also
makes me wonder what would happen if
bruno put it on i wonder if he has any
powers i wouldn't be surprised if we
actually see this happen later on down
the road it also makes you wonder if
they're skipping the whole inhuman story
because we're about to go into the
mutant side of the mcu but perhaps the x
gene is going to be unlocked in people
in a very specific way hopefully we find
that out pretty soon in the mcu now
marvel just had to take us back to that
scene in avengers end game where hawkeye
is holding on to natasha and she tells
him to let go we have pretty much the
exact same scene here with bruno and
kamala she even says you have to let me
go much like nat told clint you just had
to do it marvel you had to remind us of
that scene again but of course kamala's
okay and she said let go because she saw
that she only had to drop like two feet
now kamala and nakia go to their mosque
and there's some important scenes here
that we'll talk about in just a bit but
the main thing to take away here is that
nakia is going to run for the mosque
board she's going to try and enact some
much needed change in her mosque and
she's hoping that she can make a
difference cut to zoe's party where a
guy goes up to kamala and her friends
and offers her some orange juice he says
that there's nothing else in it but the
second she drinks it she realizes
there's vodka in it in which he confirms
this is almost taken directly from the
comics where zoe's boyfriend is actually
the one that gives vodka to kamala now
from here we meet komron and we meet him
as he does a double front flip off of a
rooftop into the pool he seems to have
some acrobatic abilities in which i'm
assuming we're going to see later when
he has to fight kamala or red dagger or
both but the cops come but komron says
he has a car and everybody jumps in and
they go on their way but of course
before he leaves he gives kamala his
phone number and says that he'll take
her for some driving lessons the next
day as bruno is dressed a lot like marty
mcfly he gets some news that he's been
accepted to the early immersion program
at caltech and that's where he's going
to be spending the next semester over
there but it's in california and a new
guy just came into kamala's life who she
seems to like but bruno likes her so he
doesn't want to leave he likes her so
much that he doesn't even want to go to
cal tech for this summer immersion
program he does try to talk to kamala
about it but she has a date with komron
so it has to wait now during this date
with komron they go to get some food at
bombay spice here they start to talk
about movies where komron actually name
drops kingo from the eternals as we know
from the eternals kingo is a very famous
bollywood star and he has been for many
many years in fact komron says that his
mother has a crush on king ghost senior
who of course we know is really just
kingo he's an eternal so he doesn't age
so instead of simply explaining that
he's an eternal he simply says that he
comes from a long generation of movie
makers and actors but in reality kingo
and kingo jr and kingo senior and any
other kingo is really just the one
person gingo now at dinner at the khan's
house we learn a very important story
about kamala's grandmother and her
great-grandmother during the partition
kamala's grandmother and
great-grandmother had to get on the last
train to leave the city but kamala's
grandmother got lost and nobody could go
look for her however she managed to make
it back to the train and the reason that
she said she was able to make it back is
because she followed a trail of stars
that was kamala's grandmother but her
mother kamala's great grandmother was
never seen again however you heard my
theory about this i think it was
kamala's great grandmother that used the
bengal to make the trail of stars for
her daughter kamala's grandmother so she
could make it safe back to the train and
she could go deal with some dangerous
people kamala has another vision that
she doesn't understand but she wants to
learn more about her great grandmother
so she calls her grandmother but she
refuses to tell her anything then kamala
the next day confronts her mother in
which she then tells kamala that her
great-grandmother brought shame to their
family and she had to travel across the
world to escape it but of course this is
not enough for kamal and she has to
investigate and really figure out what
happened let's also note that bon jovi
is canon in the mcu now now the khans
and bruno go to an eid mubarak festival
and again sorry if i mispronounced that
and there nakia is trying to secure some
votes for the mosque board there we get
introduced to a few different groups of
the mosque including the illuminantes
which is very very clever they know
everything and they gossip about
everything which is why kamala says that
that's going to be her duty because she
wants to learn more about her great
grandmother fortunately for her they
have kind of information about her and
they kind of reaffirmed to kamala the
things that her mom was saying they say
things like she was a snake she had an
affair she had a secret family she
killed the person during the partition
but doesn't get any actual information
about her now during this time nakia is
taking down her white well who is
actually kamala's father and kind of
guilt-trips him into voting for her even
though his best friend is running as
well however this means a great deal to
nakia she even has that moment in the
bathroom with kamala where she talks
about how important it was when she put
on her ajib and if i had to guess i'm
guessing nakia is going to be winning
this i'm also hoping she discovers that
kamala khan is night light miss marvel
pretty soon because meanwhile we have
the world's smartest kid about to fall
to his death and nightlight comes to the
rescue he does mention pizza ice cream
which i am kind of curious about slash
disgusted i'll let you know when i try
it yes i am going to do it as kamala
steps her way over on her hard light to
him she's asking him what things he
likes and which he says ice cream pizza
she asked him this to try to calm him
down and honestly not too bad of
thinking considering the fact that she's
a teenage superhero doing this for
pretty much the first time she manages
to temporarily save him but then the
bracelet starts glowing and she has
another vision and this time it is very
clearly najma however we don't really
know that until she picks him up in the
car but this breaks her focus which
breaks the hard light she tries to grab
him with her big extended arm much like
she would extend her limbs in the comics
but she misses after she misses she
throws a bunch of hard light at him
which kind of acts as little steps as he
falls which eventually leads to him
landing kind of okay he mentions his
ankle is hurt but hey he's not dead
meanwhile she blows up on social media
and now the dodc is looking for her now
the dodc were holding zoe kind of
captive and we're back with cleary using
the same old techniques that he used in
spider-man no way home using the same
techniques that he used on ned acting
really really nice and then going for
the kill he'd tell zoe oh yeah we watch
our youtube channel we all do we're all
big fans but then quickly flips the
switch and gets a lot of information out
of her so cut to the end of the episode
with kamala on the run and the dodc
shows up with some drones that look kind
of similar to the edith drones perhaps
these might be stark technology after
all in spider-man no way home they did
confiscate the stark technology who
knows who's using it now since we are
going to eventually lead up to armor
wars which we know is about when iron
man technology falls into the wrong
hands this could be a lead up to that
but these drones track kamala down and
so does the dodc but kamala breaks one
of them by punching them she then using
hard light manages to jump over the dodc
but they do shoot the drone and her down
this is when kamran picks her up and we
are introduced to najma now i'm thinking
now that the dodc is up to something and
if i had to guess i would say that the
dodc are either cree or scroll
specifically clery after all in
spider-man know a home cleary knew that
nick fury was off planet how did he know
that what is the connection between the
dodc and nick fury why does the
department of damage control know that
nick fury was off planet well we do know
that this is eventually going to lead up
to the marvels and secret invasion so
i'm guessing that cleary in the dodc is
either very good in working with nick
fury or very bad and working against him
and i'm assuming this will be revealed
during the series but let me know in the
meantime what you think in the comments
down below hit me with your best
theories and let me know what you
thought about miss marvel episode 2.
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest happening in the mcu for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof